one of the things we've done um it's a
secret but I can tell
you I think no nobody's listening well
is that we've just mapped the Tree of
Life using assembly Theory because
everyone said that you can't do infin
biology and what we're able to do is so
you I think there's three way well two
ways of doing Tree of Life traff uh well
three ways actually what's the tree of
life so the tree of life is basically um
tracing back the history of life on
Earth all the different species going
back what who evolved from what and it
all goes all the way back to the first
kind of life forms and they Branch off
and like you have plant kingdom the
animal kingdom the fungi Kingdom you
know and different and different
branches all the way up um and the way
this was classically done and I'm no
evolutionary biologist the evolution
biologists are very tell me every day at
least 10 times um I want to be one
though I kind of like biology it's kind
of cool but yeah it's very cool um but
BAS
what uh what Darwin and M and all these
people do is just they draw pictures
right and they they tax her they just
they were able to draw pictures and and
say and say oh these look like common
classes yeah
then there are artists really they're
just you know but they but they they
were able to find out a lot right
looking at verance in verance camon
explosion all this stuff and then um
then came the genomic Revolution and
suddenly everyone used Gene sequencing
and Craig vent is a good example I think
he's gone around the world and he's y
just taking up samples looking for new
species where he's just found new
species of life just from sequencing
it's amazing so you have taxonomy you
have sequencing and then you can also do
a little bit of kind of molecular um uh
kind of archaeology like you know
measure the samples and and kind of form
some inference what we did um is we were
able to
fingerprint so we took a load of random
samples from all of biology and we use
mass spectrometry and what we did now is
not just look for individual molecules
but we looked for coexisting molecules
where they had to look at their joint
assembly space and where we we were able
to cut them apart and and undergo
recursion in the M spec and infer some
relationships and we're able to
recapitulate the Tree of Life using mass
spectroscopy no sequencing and no
drawing all right can you uh try to say
that again again with a little more
detail so recreating what does it take
to recreate the Tree of Life what does
the reverse engineering process look
like here so what you do is you take an
unknown sample you P it into the mass
spec you get a because this comes from
what you asking like what do you see in
ecoline and so in E coli you don't just
see it's not a it's not it's not the the
most sophisticated um cells on on Earth
make the most sophisticated molecules it
is the coexistence of lots of complex
molecules above a threshold and and so
what we realize is you could fingerprint
different life forms so fungi make
really complicated molecules why because
they can't move they have to make
everything on site um whereas you know
some animals are like lazy they can just
go eat the fungi they don't need to make
very much and I um and so what you do is
you look at the so you take I don't know
the fingerprint maybe the top number of
high molecular weight molecules you find
in the sample you fragment them to get
their assembly indices
and then what you can do is you can
infer common origins of molecules you
can do a kind of
molecular um um when the reverse
engineering of the assembly space you
can infer common roots and look at
what's called The Joint assembly space
um but what let's translate that into
the experiment take a sample bung it in
the mass spec take the top say 10
molecules fragment them and then and
that gives you one fingerprint then you
you do it for another sample you get
another fingerprint now the question is
you say hey are these samples the same
or different and that's what we've been
able to do and um by basically looking
at the assembly space these molecules
create without any knowledge of assembly
Theory you are unable to do it with a
knowledge of assembly Theory you can con
reconstruct the tree how does how does
knowing if they're the same or different
give you the tree let's go to two leaves
on different branches on the tree right
what you do by counting the number of
differences you can estimate how far
away their origin was it and that's all
we do and it just works but when we
realize you could even use assembly
Theory to recapitulate the Tree of Life
with no Gene sequencing we were like huh
so this this is is looking at samples
that exist today in the world what about
like things that are no longer exist I
mean the tree contains information about
the past I would some of it is gone yeah
yeah absolutely I would love to get old
fossil samples and apply assembly Theory
MPC and see if we can find new forms of
life that have that are no longer aable
to Gene sequencing because the DNA is
all gone because DNA DNA and RNA is
quite unstable but some of the more
complex molecules might be there that
might give you a hint of something new
or wouldn't it be great if you if you
find a sample that's worth really
persevering and doing um you know doing
uh the proper extraction to re to you
know PCR and so on and then sequence it
and then put it together so when the
thing dies you can still get some
information about its complexity yeah
and we can and it appears that you can
um do some dating now there are really
good techniques there's radiocarbon
dating there is um longer dating going
looking at radioactive minerals and so
on and you can also in bone you can look
at the what happens in after something
dies is the IM the you get what's called
ramiz where the the the chirality in the
polymers basically changes and you just
get you get decomposition and the rate
of the deviation from the pure po um uh
U enantia to the mixture you can have a
it gives you a time time scale on it
halflife so you can date when it died I
want to use assembly Theory to see if I
can date use it date death and things
and and Trace the Tree of Life also
decomposition of molecules you think
it's possible oh yeah without a doubt it
may not be better than what cuz like the
I was just at a conference where some
brilliant people looking at isotope
enrichment and and looking at how life
enriches Isotopes and they're really
sophisticated stuff that they're doing
but I think there's some fun to be had
there because it gives you another
dimension of dating how old is this
molecule um in terms of and or more
importantly how long ago was this
molecule produced by life m the more
complex a molecule the more Prospect for
decomposition oxidation reorganization
loss of chirality and all that jazz but
what life also does is it enriches as
you get older the the amount of carbon
13 in you goes
up because of the because of the way the
metabol because of the way the the
bonding is in in carbon 13 so it has a
slightly different strength bond
strength from you is called a kinetic
isotope effect so you can literally date
how old you are you know uh or when you
stop metabolizing so you could date
someone's de how old they are I think
I'm making this up this might be right
but I think it's roughly right the
amount of carbon 13 you have in you you
can kind of estimate how how old you are
how
old living or humans are yeah yeah like
you could say oh this person is 10 years
old and this person's 30 years old
because they've been metabolizing more
carbon and they've accumulated it that's
the basic idea it's probably completely
wrong time scale signatures of of
chemistry are facet